you're looking at the very first meteor
from the annual perseid meteor shower
detected by NASA on the 26th of July
it's one of the biggest showers and it
reached its peak this weekend with the
waning crescent making it easier to view
last year the moon was full during the
peak
a meteor shower occurs when Earth passes
through the debris trail of a comet a
comet can be thought of as a snowball
full of Pebbles as it approaches the Sun
the ice melts leaving a trail of debris
thousands of tiny rocks no bigger than a
few centimeters in size
when the debris field enters the Earth's
orbit the air resistance around the tiny
rocks makes them glow as they become
extremely hot lighting up the sky
creating what's commonly called shooting
stars the Earth slams into them at about
two hundred thousand kilometers an hour
and and that causes the Pebbles to burst
into flame in the atmosphere and make
these spectacular light shows it's
amazing that such tiny pieces of rock
can cause something so bright
watching a meteor shower doesn't require
a telescope just a comfy spot to gaze up
at the heavens preferably outside of
urban areas with the city lights you can
see some but if you get out into the the
boonie into sort of a dark sky then
you'll see lots and lots of fainter ones
and you might see several a minute like
clockwork the perseid meteor shower
happens every year and is best seen in
the northern hemisphere
stargazers from Croatia say this year's
shower was particularly impressive
this isn't the first meteor shower I've
been here for but it is the first time
I've seen so many stars the visibility
is really great and literally every
couple of minutes a star falls big or
small it's really impressive to see
if you haven't seen it yet you can still
get out there and settle in for a free
Celestial show until at least the end of
August Mike level Al Jazeera